right so let's talk about what's
happening with um with kids here because
we have the story from fox news new
jersey sample lesson plans push videos
for fifth graders on graphic sex related
content um i mean
this was the stuff released by lips of
tick tock right was this the th yeah she
well she started it yeah i just wanted
to give her credit yeah yeah so
it seems like we're seeing an inversion
almost of what florida is doing where
florida's like hey look you know third
grade and below it's it's hits hands off
after you know fourth grade and up you
can have these conversations without
parental consent which i also think is
still kind of crazy because parents
should be signing off on you know
curriculum and knowing what's going on
but now we're seeing uh schools
having uh graphic sex related content
for for even fifth graders i think this
is a great um this is a great argument
for chris ruffo's whole transparency and
education thing which i which i love
this idea that curriculum needs to be
posted before the beginning of the year
so you can see what's going on i like it
for this reason and i like it just so
that i would know
what my kid is up to and i can like help
study what's interesting in new york is
you have uh the unelected governor kathy
holcol
pushing for um you know similar kinds of
stuff as new jersey
thoroughly opposed to the
parental rights and education bill
in florida and you have
andrew giuliani
who is also running for governor
saying that he's interested in having a
parental rights and education bill in
new york i think it's going to come down
to i think a lot of that's going to um
really come up in that in that in that
in that uh what do you call it race in
that race
i was going to say with this stuff is
what's so insane is that
with talking to the kids about the stuff
i've looked at some of these lesson
plans of course just out of educational
responsibility not because i wanted to
learn and in the way that they actually
teach the kids about sex is so
inaccurate it's absolutely crazy so you
thought porn was a bad educator for
children
it is kind of crazy they're now talking
about uh they start they're not calling
people kids anymore and they're not
using the difference between adults and
children but they're using this phrase
called young people which is this idea
of children so that's the new hot phrase
that they're using young people and this
idea of taking away man and woman old
and young adult and child and everyone's
a person x like a latinx we're all vague
and we're all a person and there's this
level of maturity i know we talked about
this before the show but some of these
educational sites that have porn on them
to teach kids about the websites you can
check them out they're cartoon porn and
unless you got some really weird
fetishes i don't think you're going to
get stumbled i don't think you're going
to really like them a lot but you go to
click in and it asks you if you're in a
if you have it says by federal law you
have to be 18 to enter the site then
asks if you're mature enough and when
you get in there the lessons on sex for
kids are so strange if somebody had told
me that's what sex is like the one i saw
up front was they were like sometimes
you get an erection you get horny and
the guy's penis was the size of his
torso it was like it was like this big
and i'm going okay i understand
exaggeration and art but if we're going
to teach kids about accuracies of sex
why are using cartoons with penis is
this four feet long that's very weird
take a look at this story from
timcast.com maryland department of
education will require pre-k students to
learn about gender identity and
expression the state's health curriculum
curriculum aims to examine how racism
impacts sexual identity by middle school
i want to break this world how racism
impacts
gender identity by middle
school hold on i got i got a bone to
pick with this your timcast.com is it a
four foot long bone will require
when you actually pull up the document
it actually has on it uh
pre-kindergarten through high school
first july 2020 to june 2021 it sounds
like they're already doing it and now i
have questions about the website but the
website is is linked through the
maryland.gov portal so this is coming
out of maryland's public school website
this document talking about
pre-kindergarten through high school and
what they're going to be teaching these
kids i don't think that it's in it it's
a it's planned opposition to what's
happening in florida i think what what
florida is is in effect of opposition to
what they've already been doing yeah and
it was already happening in florida too
and this is uh by the way talking about
the history of things i mean
comprehensive sex education
that started with with alfred kinsey was
another pedophile and and uh and and
expressly wanted to and believe wanted
to sexualize children believe that
children are sexual literally from birth
and it's a whole story there's totally
horrifying but comprehensive
comprehensive sex education goes back to
him it starts there and so it is a from
the beginning an effort to sexualize
children to sexualize them also kind of
based in this kind of circular way on
the idea that children are already
sexual from birth and the thing about
that that's so insidious because we see
that oh they're teaching this stuff to
preschoolers we find it so shocking and
it is
i mean it's horrifying but it's actually
not
surprising because well of course they
want to get to the kids that young
because when you're that when you're
four years old i mean these are the kids
who believe you know in santa claus they
like they think that spider-man is real
so
at that age psychologically they cannot
distinguish they actually cannot
distinguish between between reality and
fantasy if you go to a four-year-old
and you say to the four-year-old
superman doesn't exist they won't even
know what you mean by that doesn't mean
anything doesn't exist what do you mean
i can see him on tv i know he exists and
so that's
the left's ideas about especially about
gender are so
ridiculous and insane that they have to
get to the kids that young
at an age where they where they don't
have the mental capacity to see it for
the absurdity that it is well and if you
can indoctrinate them that young then
you get them you know potentially for
life what's funny to me is uh that's
what i was told growing up about
christianity
was that the church goes it goes tries
to get the kids so that they grow up
indoctrinated in the church and dogma
and things like that and now we're
i gotta say it is fascinating to see
that when when it comes to critical race
theory gender ideology and the general
world cult it seems that they're doing a
lot of what the left claimed the right
did a long time ago like they're they're
arguing the other side does it but
they're doing it and the difference is
so yeah you hear that argument about
that that's what that's what what
religions do and the left makes that
argument it's actually interesting
because what they're essentially
admitting is that gender ideology is a
religion and so that part i agree with
them at least we have it in the right
category it's actually a religious point
of view but the difference is that um
with christianity
you you can ask really difficult
questions
and in fact for most christians who are
informed like they want to have that
conversation let's talk about it why do
i believe in the bible why do i believe
in god let's have the conversation it's
it's great um with gender ideology
though this is why they have to get to
the kids very young
it collapses under the slightest
scrutiny they cannot answer like any
questions about it
ask them to find their terms they can't
do it and so that's that's well that's
why they resort to insults instead right
right and it's like it's like like i
asked um you know look whenever this
topic comes up we invariably uh mention
the jack dorsey rogan podcast because i
you know this conversation was about
censorship but i said to jack your rules
are inherently biased and he said no
they aren't and i said you have a
misgendering policy that enforces the
left's world view on what misgendering
means the right things misgendering is
if someone is biologically male or
female you use inverted pronouns and the
left thinks if someone chooses to use
pronouns you don't use them you've
decided to enforce what the left thinks
i asked would you enforce these rules he
was like well look we do this because
there's high suicide rates and we're
trying to protect people and i said sure
but you don't do that for anyone else's
suicidal you don't say you can't
disparage police officers or dentists
you don't say that you can't disparage
people who are who are dysmorphic in
terms of anorexia or bulimia yeah
soldiers have an insanely combat
veterans have an insanely high suicide
rate nobody says that means you can't
criticize u.s foreign
offense on youtube youtube wait wait
criticizing u.s foreign policy is a
bannable offense because of content
actually technically it can be monetized
if you talk about ukraine or russia the
wrong way now that that's absolutely
true the rules actually say i i'm pretty
sure youtube says you'll be banned for
disparaging someone based on their
veteran status yeah but that's different
that's different that's not um
if you're disparaging someone for the
veteran status that's different from
criticizing the broader ideologies
yeah that's the point right right you're
saying hey like i've heard people say
this all the time should have never been
in that war you know and i i've
literally watched this not only on on
youtube but in every social media
something to this regard of going yeah
you know imagine your brother died in
afghanistan and then you see now the
pull out especially when we were leaving
and that the war they say was for
nothing and what do you feel about your
brother's death i mean that would be
something that i would say as a family
member imagine i'm heartbroken and i'm
sitting there and someone's railing onto
it it might put me in a position where i
would feel unstable emotionally does my
life matter but i also think that the
key thing about the trans thing you have
to realize is like i i this is gonna
sound crazy to some people but i think
you can't talk about this without being
somewhat theological or at least if
you're not theological metaphysical you
could put it into this there is a
depopulation agenda and it seems that we
always prioritize the social issues that
lead to population it's like whether
it's the trans identity whether it's and
we target when they're young
specifically in puberty we're not
fighting for transsexual adults we're
fighting for transgenderism a state of
mind specifically in kids it's for
abortion in the womb it's for climate
change and reducing our emission and the
amount of people in the carbon footprint
about reducing our intake biosynthetic
meat about not having access to things
when you look at the amalgamation of all
of the targets of the the global agenda
i'd say the western global agenda uh
specifically eu united states the five
eyes et cetera so when you go there it
all seems hell-bent on somehow bringing
this down now that this is not
antithetical to what the actual elites
talk about very regularly in davos and
also too just openly like on public
forums and i hate to be like the bill
gates guy but i just people talk about
there's too many people there's too many
and there's just not i know but yeah no
i totally i agree with you so yeah
that's where the social issues yeah what
is the common link the common link is
about making us less accessible to
resources to ideas to expand to grow and
to shrink but shrinking the population i
would say um perhaps these pieces line
up but i would also be careful because
that that's the territory where you're
you're
far removed from the average person
doesn't understand what's going on it's
very very simple to go to a middle-class
working family and say you know would
you be in support of your 13-year-old
son getting large breast implants and
then being like excuse me get out of my
house it's much more it's much different
if you go to them and say let me break
down very quickly for you this deep
population agenda why i think they're
doing these things this is this is the
issue um you know it's really funny i
went on candace kennedy's owen's show
earlier and she was fantastic by the way
but she mentioned we're talking about
alex jones and how
you know a lot of what he says might be
too colorful for regular people to
understand when he you know i mentioned
that the media comes out and says you
know he's yelling the frogs are gay or
whatever and she was like but he was
right
i mean not overtly about frog being gay
but that you know there's a chemical
that was you know causing problems and
you know for frogs and i said right a
chemical called atrazine was reportedly
interfering with the endocrine systems
of frogs and alex jones yelled out
turning the frogs gay or whatever and uh
the media takes that to poison the well
so i try to be careful with messaging
but i get what you're saying i think
it's more tactful to just approach the
issues individually because i think most
regular working people agree that
individually these things are all are
all issues we're facing well it is
interesting i think with the climate
change specifically because
um there is this uh you guys have heard
extinction rebellion oh i've met a lot
of those guys before very funny so
they're very opposed to anybody having
children
right i'm hope they don't have and i
hope they you know maybe they don't have
them but um but that's sort of the idea
is that like people should not have
children
that it's a drain on the earth's
resources and all of this but it's like
the less people we have the less
resources we're going to have because
there's going to be less people to do
the work to gather the resources or to
create the new things and this is
actually well this would be fair real
quick they're saying
the amount of say uh oil in the ground
will be consumed by a billion people but
a million people will consume a you know
order of magnitude several order
magnitude several orders have mentioned
less they're not saying that they're you
know like i understand what you mean
there will be less refined resources but
their argument is yeah it's so rare we
can't even we can't even well they value
they value the earth over
the earth's inhabitants exactly and
that's an issue so i would make two
points first well can i so firstly what
you're saying is verified by basically
all of the statistics that we have on
population growth and wealth world
population has exploded in global
poverty has decreased significantly in
that time human beings have a remarkable
ability not only to provide for
themselves but for others as well and so
the left has this way of looking at
resources which is very fixed pie and
very childish they think that there's
just been this fixed number of resources
that we've had access to from the
beginning of time and we've been slowly
dwindling them down
failing to comprehend the fact that as
new people with new minds come along
they find new ways to use what we
already have and ways to use what we
thought was useless in the past
ben shapiro made an excellent point i
saw this viral video where he was asked
about climate change and why he didn't
think was an emergency i think he gave a
very verbose answer but his uh his
ending
his his last point was he doesn't think
it's a disaster because the um the
predictions don't account for mitigation
factors meaning you know they look at
these these charts say oh we're going to
have uh 10 feet of water rise in 100
years
burying cities 200 feet and you know in
the next thousand and it's gonna wipe
out all these cities and it's like right
right and you're not accounting for the
fact that human adaptation happens right
which you you go back to that famous
story about horse manure in new york
you're familiar with this one
yeah they said at the turn of the
century we are going to be buried under
horse manure in new york city because
there's too many horses and too much
manure they kind of are yeah well
they're buried under humans
but then they invented the car and all
of a sudden the horse manure problem
changed now i do think there there's
there's an obvious mathematical equation
that the planet can only sustain so many
human beings and i don't know uh how
many how i don't know what that number
is i don't think we've got there yet but
we're not close i'm not entirely sure i
agree i think you know a lot of people
talk about there's not that many humans
the planet is almost entirely empty it's
like yes but are there enough humans to
disrupt a sim a a large chemical process
say in the north atlantic current
my issue is i do think population
density is a huge problem new york is a
large concrete block that can't sustain
itself and it creates massive pools of
waste and insane yeah that's but that's
the problem is is the way humans are
choosing to congregate but you could
take the entire population the globe and
put them in texas and they still have
they still a good amount of space it's
just that we you know you have these
vast expanses of land that aren't used
and we we choose to to pile into cities
and so on so that's but that's true but
consider this um
you know you could take the entire you
said the entire population of the planet
pilot in texas right yeah but uh real
estate everybody would have a nice how
much ammonia needs to be produced to
disrupt uh the you know the ocean's
ecosystem or or a natural uh cycle of
like the ecosystem on this planet it we
don't need to flood the planet with
ammonia we don't need to but or you know
other chemicals but humans do produce
waste products and it's not just you
know the human literal waste products
it's uh chemical byproducts and plastics
so my concern is the amount of waste
produced by humans to disrupt the entire
planet is probably not as it's not going
to be like you know 10 of the planet
surface of garbage destroys the planet
it could be 0.01 causes of chemical
disruption which disrupts the ecosystem
we've seen things like dead zones in the
gulf dead zones in oceans where there's
no oxygen and no no life can can can
live and there's the north pacific
garbage gyre the garbage gyres are
really really bad yeah and uh this has
an impact on
life cycles so that's the entire planet
like
that for example is not a population
problem per se it's just what the people
are choosing to do it's like it's like
you know these you could go to uh some
of these rivers in asia are just
moving garbage dumps people just
throwing
uh their their uh waste products into
the river meanwhile like in america
we're blaming ourselves because of our
plastic straws or whatever and then
we've got paper straws and they suck
right exactly exactly and then masks
everywhere right they're everywhere like
the mask thing they they choke the trees
the way plastic bags used to be then
you've got it you've got other parts of
the world and it's like they're the
rivers are literally just like conveyor
belts for trash out to the ocean but
that's that's uh that's why people are
choosing to join you don't have to do
that but scale it up but now we have
microplastics in our bodies
eliminate human technological byproducts
there is a point at which humans fart
themselves to death yeast does it in in
in a bottle but the question is i'm not
saying we're there i don't know where it
will be but mathematically it's obvious
that it exists now my point on top of
this is so i think pollution is a
problem i think we should be aware of
that and do our best to mitigate that to
live as clean as possible minimize our
entropy maximize our entropy but also in
the process we should be colonizing
other planets we should be doing
scientific advancement we should be
launching space station i think we
should be doing all of that stuff yeah i
think we should be totally like using
the resources we have to
bust out of the solar system
why because we are a race of explorers
and uh
a real answer fun is a real answer
humanity can be wiped out by a single
comet right now if we had a but a small
space station on mars the humans on mars
would be would not be impacted by a
crisis on earth in the same way making
us more resilient and more prone to
survival that's a good reason too
and fun can i actually say i actually
prefer the fun answer i think that's
because just from up front you know if
you try to argue that like from a
practicality standpoint we have to build
colonies on mars i mean mars is is the
what would be required for for our
planet to be more inhospitable than mars
i mean it's like uh at that point
probably humanity no longer exists
anyway i actually couldn't we like mine
the asteroid belt that would be cool and
that's the thing i i actually i'm in
favor of colonizing um the solar system
if we can not really because it's
practically makes a lot of practical
sense but just because that's what
humanity is meant to do you're meant to
just right to strive for the horizons
and i think when you stop doing that
then you're basically giving up on human
civilization i'm against it to be
completely honest i'm so in favor
colonialism yes actually because i don't
want to i don't want the rock monsters
to have to identify with a new species
should we be reaching out like we you
know we had the exploration age and we
were when you had people on ships and
they were going across uncharted waters
and we don't have that anymore so where
do you go now i mean when you look at
the global amounts of money that it's
taking to fund this stuff i bring up
this problem with it and this is an
interesting perspective that i think
really deviates if you hold like a
christian worldview or an atheist
worldview that i think we have to
understand because obviously if you're
eschatologically you know sound in some
way even if you are in another religion
but specifically christianity which is
the major religion in the united states
you know there's this understanding that
at the end times it says that people
will be saying like life how always has
been and always will be people will be
given in marriage they will be trading
when when god comes to judge the world
in that way then there's an
understanding that judgment comes when
god comes to judge the world and the end
of the age the end of the world is in
god's hands and we're not going to just
get struck with a comet however if you
don't believe that then i totally even
understand what you're saying because
that is a total probability like
scientifically what you're saying by the
way makes 100 logically but i want to
make this point though about the
colonization is sometimes i think that
humans we have this uh big man syndrome
where i agree with the exploration and
my wife was really having a difficult
time i've been watching like cave
accidents and she was like why are
people going into caves and and this is
where i would concede your point i said
dude exploration and this idea of of
pushing the boundaries is part of the
human spirit that god gave us but
going into space is sort of a
taxpayer-funded burden that i feel in
many ways i mean the private the
privatization of it what's happening now
is still very interesting as we're
moving in that but overall it's been
very costly i've always wondered those
resources and that movement with going
to mars almost seems like a distraction
that we talk about you know he's going
into space and it's like i get it we
have problems here i don't know that i
don't think those actually solve yeah
but when we but
when we start exploring there's a couple
points that have to be made it's not
popular
other problems uh yes technological
advancements that came from
taxpayer-funded space exploration
and the money is spent doesn't leave
anywhere it's cycled into the economy
and is good for the economy that people
are working on these technologies often
when we have factories machining a lot
of these parts they remain and can
machine other parts so technological
technological advancement is just good
across the board also it lets us dream
it it gives us oh it gives us a place to
put our our fantasies and our imaginings
and our hopes for the future here's a
you're asking what problem does it solve
well i think our our most fundamental
problem in our society right now is is
like malaise and despair people have
just given up on life given up on life
having any meaning and i'm not saying
that space exploration solves that but
it is it's a it is a it helps anyway in
that regard i mean when was the last
time
that united states of america were like
united over together over something good
that happened celebrating a good thing
that happened when's the last time that
ever that that we had the united states
probably the moon landing i was gonna
say since chauvin got convicted uh that
was the last time i saw everyone
i really think the moon landing the
moonlighting was the last time that the
united states had a good thing that
everybody together was cheering um and
so
not even caitlyn jenner no no but the
argument
the argument there the argument there is
this is it i and i want to say this
people even argue whether that happened
or not i don't have a strong opinion on
the moon landing but i will say it
definitely well i know i'm saying people
just it really did happen people in the
chat are going to argue i'm saying when
you say that i'm saying but i'm not
going to argue about i don't think so i
think they're mostly going to say it
happened okay well i don't know i've
been seeing movement what i'm saying is
i don't want to get stuck on that i want
to say yes i agree that moment was a
total unifying factor and absolutely
amazing what space exploration appears
to be today is number one the
militarization of the outer hemisphere
is number two it seems to be not a
national idea of a space race of us
coming together and having a national
unity it seems to be who can afford a
ticket to go out into the solar system
and actually get out there it seems more
like a like another rich man's ploy to
escape earth
new technology always exists for the
wealthy and also we had you know we had
a government-funded space program that
has now brought us to a point where we
have private citizens who are able to
further space research that's cool
that's part of it that's part of the
capitalist undertaking i'm not going to
win anybody over here
imagine being like microwaves so you
need to cook your food 10 minutes faster
rich people buy the stupidest things
just use this stuff well eventually
everybody gets it thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8 00 pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time